hi tnc hi martin what's going on
i'm writing a ride hailing app that
matches cars
with riders in real time using pub sub
i noticed some glitches and i wondered
if you could help me
a ride hailing app that sounds super
cool
pubsub has released several new features
this year
i wonder if some of them could help
could you tell me more about your use
cases
of course
[Music]
when a rider requests a ride the rider's
mobile app
sends an http post to a cloud run
service called
writer handler that service publishes a
message to pubsub
the message is consumed by the
dispatcher service
the dispatcher service calls the fleet
manager service
to find nearby drivers it then sends a
push notification
to the nearest driver via firebase cloud
messaging
when a driver accepts or declines a ride
their mobile app calls the cloud run
service called driver handler
that service publishes a message to pub
sub which is consumed by the fleet
manager service
pubsub lets me decouple rider handler
from dispatcher
and driver handler from fleet manager
it also lets me add more message to
subscribers in the future
for example for reporting thank you for
showing me how the app works
i see how pub stop fits in now let's see
the issues you face
yeah the first issue i'm facing is
caused by malformed
gps data from writers phones it's still
a little bit of a mystery to me how this
happens
but when a dispatcher receives pubsub
messages with bad
gps data it throws an exception and
doesn't acknowledge the message
when there are many such bad messages
new ride requests
don't make it to the dispatcher oh no
it sounds like you've built a growing
backlog of undeliverable messages
in your pops up topic could you show me
the graphs
for on next message count
and oldest enact message yeah
i went into the pub sub area of cloud
console and i took these screenshots
ah this confirms my suspicion
let me explain a small backlog is
harmless
but a huge backlog could cause all your
messages to be stuck
because pubsub always tries to deliver
the oldest messages first
you never want a situation where the
number of undelivered messages grows
with the age of
the oldest message it looks like you
have that kind of
backup and it's causing new messages to
be stuck
behind the old messages oh i see
uh what should i do you should use a
dead letter queue
you could tell pops up to forward the
undeliverable messages
to a different topic also known as
a dead letter topic after a certain
number of
failed delivery attempts oh really
can i update an existing subscription to
send bad messages to a dead letter queue
absolutely let's go to cloud console to
do that
okay let's go to your subscription
dispatch us up all right
edit it edit yep
we want to scroll down to death
lettering and
enable that lettering
this checkbox here that's right
to forward the messages all right
uh so i'll call that writers that letter
topic
you also want to attach a default
subscription
to your ledger topic okay
i'll call that um
writer's dead letter subscription
sounds great how many times do you want
pupsup to try
before it forwards the bet messages
so this is how many times it will have
to fail in dispatcher before it comes
into this
subscription is that right that's
correct
okay uh maybe 10 times if it doesn't
work after 10 it will never work
uh now you can click update
all right
and you want to go to death lettering ah
yeah there's an orange triangle there
this is to grant pub sub the publish and
subscriber role
so that it could forward messages on
your behalf
oh i see so i just granted these roles
yes you expect messages that exceed
the maximum number of delivery attempts
to be forwarded
to your debt letter topic excellent
i should ask for someone who knows more
about gps data
to write a service that subscribes to
that dead letter subscription
and do a full diagnosis they will have
all the bad data in one place
i think they'll appreciate that the
second issue i have
is mistakenly sending cars to pick up a
writer
who has cancelled first the writer sends
a request
right message next the writer sends a
cancel
right message if they want to cancel the
right and for some reason
the castle write message sometimes
arrives first
when it does the dispatcher doesn't know
about this right yet so it can't cancel
it
and then later the request drive message
comes in
and the dispatcher then creates the
rides and finds a driver
for this cancelled ride this sounds like
messages were definitely arriving out of
order
but pops of message ordering could help
oh excellent please tell me more
i imagine requests matter per writer
when these requests are published to
pops up
if you attach the writer's id
as an ordering key then these messages
will be delivered in the same order they
are received by popsup
the request write message will arrive in
a dispatcher service
first followed by the cancel right
message
oh and this would make sure that the
dispatcher is always using the latest
correct information about each ride
right
exactly i want to give it a try uh how
do i set it up tnc
uh to set it up let's go to call console
again
all right i'm here i go into
subscriptions
um let's recreate a dispatcher sub
so that it has ordering enabled
so i start by deleting it is that right
that's right all right
delete
and then i'll create a new a replacement
for it
so i'll call it dispatcher sub ordered
because
it sounds great yeah and it's the
writers topic
it's push because we're using cloud run
on the other side
and uh this is my cloud run endpoint
and i'm just recreating what i've done
on the previous subscription
so i enable authentication for it i set
up an account for that
and then there was something i should do
differently
ordering yes that's it yes
you want to enable message ordering very
good and that's it
uh that's it you can click create
all right and in the meantime i'm going
to
publish a request request write message
from bobcat followed by a cancer right
message
from bobcat all right
i'm selecting the log for the dispatcher
service here
and there i see a request ride
from bobcat and let's see
this yeah and a council ride from bobcat
oh drivers will appreciate this they
came in in the right order
ah that's great to hear cool so with
dead letter queues
and message ordering enabled i'm eager
to test out a new
version of the algorithm in the
dispatcher that matches
writers and drivers definitely
it would be cool to compare the
algorithms side
by side i'm thinking if you can replay
the messages
you can compare the new algorithm with
the old algorithm
cool that sounds fantastic but you can
can you explain what
replay means to replay messages
you need to create a snapshot on a given
subscription
another way to think about a snapshot is
to consider it
a recording that you start okay
i have a subscription which hits the
production dispatcher we just saw it
if i want to replay messages to my test
dispatcher
and compare it with the one in
production can i do that
absolutely let's head over to cloud
console to do that
all right let me just first grab my the
address for the
test dispatcher all right so i grabbed
the url for the test dispatcher
and i'm going to pub sub subscriptions
now um yes
let's go to dispatch yourself ordered
all right dispatcher sub ordered i'm
going into that let's go into the
subscription
and create a snapshot
okay
great snapshot all right
let's give it a name all right maybe
i'll call it begin test
all right uh and now we want to go ahead
and create a new subscription
using this snapshot so go to
subscriptions
okay create new subscription you said
yes
all right uh i think i might call this
a test dispatcher subscription
and this will be the same topic as the
previous one
still push because i'm pushing to a
cloud run
service here's the url for my test
dispatcher
i've set up a service account that can
publish is allowed to publish
and allow to call the cloud run service
and
uh sorry what more should i do here
i you want to retain
acknowledge the messages uh oh
there it is retain acknowledge messages
yep
um and go ahead and create
this subscription all right
very quickly martin could we go back to
sub dispatcher sub ordered
and also retain acknowledge the messages
in
um dispatches have ordered
as well yes of course good good thinking
uh so was it retain acknowledged
messages
that's right okay i'm going to go ahead
and
publish some messages in the meanwhile
you can go to your test subscription
and seek to the snapshot that you just
created
oh okay test dispatcher sub
and replay messages
and seek to a snapshot you said
yes okay should i hit seek
yes
very good replaying messages
uh-huh and
now we can look at your logs
to see some messages that i just
published
all right um in the logs i'm going to
filter so that i only see the test
dispatcher
let's see the messages from the test
dispatcher let's see
here
so test dispatcher received a request
ride
from starfish
and let's see if there were any more
i'll run this again
uh test dispatcher received a pop up
message request right from penguin
uh a request right from gopher
and finally there was a request right
from starfish
cool that's awesome so any point i can
go back and
and replay these and send them over and
over to
the test dispatcher the snapshot will be
there for
seven days so you can go back and replay
as many times as you want
cool so i see that i can seek to a
snapshot and the
other option i see here is to seek to
a point in time this is a really
powerful feeling
being able to jump around in time
right it's empowering but we should
probably
also want to do with caution by reading
the docs carefully
yeah i can't agree more we time
travelers
know that we must always read the
documentation carefully
i feel like i've learned a lot today tnc
dead lettering
ordering snapshot and seek thank you for
showing me these pops up features
a pleasure martin let me know how your
right healing app does
[Music]
you